[Music]
yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is about the Moscow variation of
the Sicilian yeah this is an important
line as it will happen very frequently
in your games if you face the Sicilian
so what is the Moscow variation okay we
deal with this move order to d6 with to
d6 black usually a signal some the
intention to play yeah neither off
dragon maybe a classical Sicilian we
don't go for all that we don't play d4
the open Sicilian but we go for me it
should be five check and this check is
the Moscow variation sometimes it's
pretty clear what the region of a name
is but for the Moscow variation I have
no clue I tried to find out but came up
empty so what does that check do of
course it develops piece and prepares to
Castle so very healthy move I have to
mention that for many many years this
move was always viewed as somewhat lame
somewhat meat choice however in recent
years and talking about like 10 12 15
years it has seen a huge urgent
popularity mostly due to the efforts of
some top players who really got fed up
with them
yeah unsuccessfully playing against the
night off and most prominent of courses
were champion Magnus cards and was
played to check really really a lot so
we should be 5 check good thing is there
we have limited there's a limited choice
for black hair due to the check the
first move and easiest to look at for
this particular video is the move Knight
to c6 this is the direct transpose
- the Roscoe animo variation with d6 so
this is examined ryeom this move water
yeah
d6 it's um yeah this position arises
like equally from from both move orders
and I felt the knight on c6 gives it
more of a Roscoe D more flavor so I put
this yeah I choose to put it as a part
of the Roscoe Lee more chapter so he had
this video after Bishop d5 check we
examine ninety-seven and Bishop d7 I'd
like to start with 97 which always has
been again less popular than Bishop d7
however the 97 has some points it is um
arguably the sharper move because black
does not want to with Bishop d7 allow an
easy trade but rather says okay I put
tonight on to d7 you have to move your
Bishop began if I go a six
well maybe take on yourself giving black
the bishop pair this is a bit sharper
this movement Bishop d7 white now has a
number of options and in a sexually
tough to say what the mainline is maybe
actually d4 is the mainline but this
move which is somewhat logical and we
open up the center because 97 is clawing
out blacks development and this move
might be the most popular but I don't
think it is all that advantageous for
white and it was too close for my taste
to an open Sicilian so I did not go for
D form an interesting recent development
in this line is that white has played
the move castles a lot and after a six
play Bishop to d3 this is quite
interesting and can be a good
alternative to the main recommendation
however it felt a little bit too
unnatural for me to put it into a keep
it simple repertoire there are a
particular
some really wacky lines that Lincoln
tribe and that are quite irritating to
study it doesn't feel so again so smooth
to me this kind of play compared to what
I actually chose but this is not not bad
objectively speaking so 97 I recommend
to move c3 yeah what is this a point
with c3 we open up a retreat square for
the bishop on c2 this is important as
blacks neck smooth or yeah next move or
move after that it's probably going to
be a six and we need a good square for
the bishop as we have seen with the
slide I just showed one minute ago after
castles you only have that somewhat
awkward d3 Square and with pawn to c3
here we make sure that via a for c2 we
have a good spot down the bishop once
the two supports the centre and helps
get to prepare what's one central
development so I think this is a very
sensible move black knob may go a6
immediately I'll play Knight f6 he will
very likely play a six in the near
future so there are many trans positions
it should be mentioned that the play
that we will get now in many cases looks
a lot like a Spanish game like a window
pass and this is something to keep in
mind the black player has started the
game not with one e5 but with c5 and d6
so he might be completely booked up in
an IDE or for Dragon and wants to play a
super-sharp game with opposite opposite
sides castles and now he has to play the
black side of a window pass in some
cases structure not particularly and
this is important to remember very
likely he's in a position type that he
is not that he does not know all that
well and wasn't really aiming for so
let's start with a 690 f6 is the more
frequently seen move but just a sixth
show it has very little independent
we go Bishop inform put the bishop on to
c2 and black were very likely developed
like that after which Queen to e2 world
transposed to a position that we will
examine via the move order 490 f6 so
there is a little difference between a
six now and Knight f6 immediately let's
look at night f6 okay the pawn is
hanging and in this particular situation
the most natural movers of course Queen
t2 we put the Queen they are to cover
the e4 pawn and now black has a wide
range of possibilities he can play with
E 5 some combination of a 6b 585 he can
play with e6 that's also possible he six
or you can try some g6 base set up there
are many many different options that he
may may go for our plane is fairly
similar we will play d4 and support the
center and in almost all cases white is
going to be yeah very very slightly
better let's have a look them a six
first maybe em well let's say no I think
it's probably better to look at the
eponymous first so II five is a
possibility and this is not as precise
actually as playing a six immediately
because after deform we now have the
option to conveniently retreat this
bishop this is in fact quite nice
because if you think of it after a six
b5 Bishop a4 Bishop c2 the bishop does
almost the same job but here we just
take one move instead of two so it's a
little bit better for example here twin
to c7 castles and white is going to be
slightly better we just have a better
central control instead of E 5 there's
also a 6 immediately but after d4 as6
Bishop d3
we are again somewhat better if you see
the positions after a six B five and
then like Judas is set up you see what I
mean this is a slightly more comfortable
version of the main line for white one
key point by the way in such situations
where black puts pawns on d6 and e6 is
to time the advance you forty five
correctly often be forty five will be a
useful move to make to open up this
diagonal but you give up the d5 square
the Black Knight will come there so it's
a case of getting squares giving away
squares it's a very double-edged
decision but note that white with more
space oftentimes is simply able to keep
the tension in the center and just
support it delaying this decision so we
have more options than then black hairs
I hope you enjoyed this preview of the
keep it simple
efore repertoire you can get the full
course on chasuble calm which features
the move trainer that makes it easy and
simple to learn all the nice and
remember them all lights are chosen with
one thing in mind keep it simple for you
and make it difficult for your opponent
[Music]
you